one of the other terms that you use a
lot is hypergamy
um can you just explain what hypergamy
means that was the first time i'd ever
heard that term before yeah first time i
heard it was 2017 and all that really is
is just a definition of
women's sexual strategy which is
only
hair bonding with somebody that's of a
equal or higher socioeconomic
status so
um i take these call-ins on my show i
don't know if you ever watched the
unplugged alpha podcast but i had this
guy call in
on monday this week and he was 36 his
girlfriend was 46 she was an
entrepreneur successful many multiples
more money and one of the conversation
pieces that came up was she wanted him
to start his own business so he could
make more money
because
he was only making 200 000 a year she
made several multiples higher
what he didn't see is that she's not
happy with that he doesn't understand
that women are hypergamous and you know
for her to be happy for her to wake up
in the morning and look at the guy and
be like yeah this is the best that i can
do because that's all that
hypergamy is you know you want to make
wake up you want to look at your
boyfriend you want to get a text from
and read it and think to yourself yeah
this guy's like the man
yeah right
as soon as you look at that guy and
you're like he's not anymore then that's
when women tend to wander so there's
there's a lot of guys that obsess with
hypergamy and
women will never be loyal to you and
blah blah blah sort of thing because of
it but it's a loser's mindset and they
and they generally take the wrong
approach i mean if you recognize that
women want to be with the best
like the best version of a male that
they can possibly get
why not be that guy
why not learn how to make money why not
stop being fat why not develop some
style
you know you can go right down the list
of all those things right like be the
guy that she wants
it almost makes them keep their their
standard for themselves higher
right
yeah because so many times you get
married and then everybody gains some
weight and they stop trying and then the
women
clearly are going to practice that
hypergamy and look for something better
because that man is no longer serving
what they want
yeah yeah it's a it's a multifaceted
puzzle like it's not just one piece like
sometimes people focus too much on the
money aspect of it but
women just don't focus on money like
they actually have to be attracted to a
guy you know despite the whole body
positivity movement there's a reason why
there's no chubby chaser dating sites
for women looking for fat guys
they don't exist
well they're all trying to do this whole
dad bod thing and get on that game i'm
i'm not about that like there's
there's loads of women that'll be
interviewed publicly on a you know like
a youtube channel on a news station
being asked about dad bods and they'll
say oh yeah it's cute that's sexy i love
dad bots but watch what they choose like
when they go the nightclub they're going
out with the rock hard fireman right
right
right but are they marrying the firemen
sometimes sometimes they're dating the
dadbot guy am marrying him because he's
got the money so that's the alpha seed
beta neat equation of women's dating
strategy right it's it's dualistic
because of their cycles
yeah
that's so interesting all this [ __ ] like
just fascinates me and i got into this
because i wanted to understand men
better and
figure out how
how to support them like obviously this
is a dual this takes men and women to
figure out and actually work together on
um
yeah
it does but i mean like it really it
really needs the man to lead the
equation like if the guy's not unplugged
like if he's uh
you know if he's a blue pill beta sort
of thing
you guys can want to work on as much as
you can but what ends up happening is
you end up working on him then you find
out that it doesn't go anywhere and he's
not
getting to the point where you want him
to and then you get bored and you kind
of move on from it sort of thing
so it really starts with a guy like it
it really truly does start with him
wanting to be the leader wanting to
you know procure this information and
and and fix the chaos that's gone on in
his life and this usually what leads
guys to stuff like this you know like i
mentioned earlier when you were asking
you know how i got into this it's it's
because of chaos in my own life and it's
usually a cert you know that sequence of
bad decisions you know the chaos whether
it's
girl chieftain you divorce it usually
ties around with women
then that's when you go looking for the
information and then you're like okay
now it's time for me to take
responsibility for all this stuff
let's you know let's build let's build
back better as our friend
only you're not building back a better
beta you're actually ending that that
that beta version of yourself and you're
on unplugging from all the [ __ ] and
then you become the unplugged alpha
yeah
and
i i encourage women to do that so i host
retreats for women to do the same thing
to kind of find their femininity again
what do you teach them
so we do the retreats and
we come in and we do boudoir pictures
like women forget to
dress up to feel sexy like not just for
their man but for themselves because
when they feel sexy then they actually
want to have sex and like it just
it catapults into so many different
areas of their lives then they realize
okay now i'm worth it i need to start
working out i need to you know do stuff
with my kids and
just the transformations that i've seen
with these women based off of a weekend
um
it's pretty cool but they're like you
start immediately with the optics of
femininity and beauty by putting them in
um scantily clad clothing and taking
photographs
yeah that's probably the right place to
start to be honest with you
yeah
and
well and we're taught that that's not
okay which i think is [ __ ] like
we're we no longer feel sexy okay well
then we're only wearing our sweats
around and you know where that comes
from
no toxic feminism it it tells women to
never do anything for the express
pleasure of men don't look beautiful
don't dress beautiful don't put on
makeup don't do dinner don't do the
dishes make sure he does half of
everything blah blah blah so that so
that entire you know societal narrative
comes from women's belief that they
should never really do anything for the
pleasure of men but the truth of the
matter is women don't fall in love with
guys when they're doing things for them
they fall in love with guys when women
are doing things for the guy
yes
yes
that's when you lose yourself in your
self sort of thing it's like oh my god i
can't believe i'm doing all these things
for this guy i've never done that before
for anybody else
yeah and when you actually respect a man
who is an alpha you'll do anything for
him i i love all the references that you
talk about like
anal and shooting a load in your mouth
like that is true if a woman respects
you as the
book for men so i so i had to
cater to an audience but yeah it does
not it doesn't you know embarrass me at
all um but it's true if a woman is like
no i don't do that
with you
that's what she should be saying
yeah hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you